Non
le tableau mentionné a été trouvé à
un grenier adossé à un mur
donc pas très bon état mais
immédiatement également grâce à la présence de
notre ami officiel français de
immédiatement et aussi à ses yeux
nous avons lu que la porte était en bon état
conditions et cela nous a rendu heureux mais
ils m'ont vraiment semblé complètement
couple de sujets chinois en famille
mais ils avaient l'air d'avoir absolument
a également profité de ce petit
connaissance de ces sujets
à propos de toute cette affaire et je le pense
pour pouvoir le vérifier au moins
[Musique]
nous sommes si heureux, si fiers de
je l'ai trouvée
pourquoi est-ce ici le monument à un
épisode fondamental de notre vie
histoire récente
c'est-à-dire un épisode dans lequel cela nous a fait
douter de notre certitude
la liberté de la certitude qui nous est propre
croyances et quand un artiste sait
traduisez-les avec son travail
sentiments de douleur d'incertitude
ça ressemblait à une rame comme à un taureau
ruelles et tablette femme Moscone di Pio
ix devant le bonino
comme le nombre total de lieux où le glissement de terrain
traître si les choses à ton sujet ne vont pas, tu n'es pas poly
Le bouddhisme aversana à voir
savoureux et nous montrerons comment nous avons eu
a cru
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enya un seul gag
après l'e scientifique
et j'espère vraiment faire des folies, directeur
pour pouvoir se mettre au cou, personne ne l'admet
pure classe, tu as l'impression d'être dans des conditions
optimal pour le Dow Jones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]